uno de ustedes de las personas que ven
mis vídeos me hizo notar de manera
correcta que una de las definiciones de
retorno sobre activos entonces todo este
vídeo va a ser de retorno sobre los
activos que una definición de retorno
sobre activo y bueno lo puedes ver en
algunos sitios financieros o incluso en
algunos libros de textos de finanzas me
dijo que una definición es ingreso neto
ingreso neto dividido entre activo total
entre activo total esto es distinto a lo
que yo te dije en otras fuentes a saber
en wikipedia te van a dar otra
definición entonces esta es una de acá
de retorno sobre activos y otra
definición es ingreso neto déjame
ponerlo como y en ingreso neto más
interés entonces están agregando el
interés menos tenemos que restar el
impuesto que nos ahorramos por el
interés entonces es menos el ahorro de
impuestos
el interés podemos hacer después un
vídeo acerca de ahorros de impuestos por
interés cuando tiene sentido financiar
un poco de tu activo con deuda en vez de
capital por el costo de los impuestos
eso aumenta un poco tus posibilidades de
bancarrota pero después hablaremos más
de eso entonces es todo esto de acá
dividido entre activo entre el activo
total esta es la definición que te da
wikipedia y luego también está la otra
definición verdad la primera que yo te
vi que era utilidad operativa utilidad
operativa
dividida entre activo
voy a agregar una más y una definición
más en este vídeo porque creo que es
importante hablar de algo que pasa mucho
en finanzas luego hay muchas fórmulas
para cosas la gente se las memoriza pero
pues luego en el proceso se pierde mucho
la intuición y pues también es muy
importante darse cuenta que hay muchas
formas de definir un mismo concepto
verdad a lo mejor la gente puede decir
el roba fue tanto pero sabes que siempre
es una buena idea preguntarles qué
quieres decir
roa para ellos te sorprenderías por la
cantidad de personas que no lo pueden
explicar a la primera bueno la última
que quiero poner es edit ebit es una
palabra rara pero ese vídeo entre activo
ahora nuevas para que sepas ebit quiere
decir ganancias antes de intereses e
impuestos pero en inglés verdad esto es
lo mismo que el ingreso neto más el
interés
más los impuestos dividido entre activo
entonces como un roa antes de impuestos
va a activo todo esto de aquí son cosas
diferentes y puedes decir mira osea
fíjate bueno vamos a hablar tanto de
evitó vamos a comparar el bit con
utilidad operativa inmediatamente
podrías decir a ver si tomo la el
ingreso neto para ver déjame escribir
aquí que era evit recuerda evites
ganancias antes de intereses e impuestos
pero en inglés ok entonces si nuestras
ganancias fueron de 350 mil pesos y a
eso le sumamos el impuesto y el interés
más el impuesto verdad que si estoy acá
más el interés entonces obtenemos la
utilidad operativa al menos en este
ejemplo verdad entonces podrías
preguntarte por qué está esta palabra de
aquí ebit que esta media o rara porque
usamos evite en vez de decir utilidad
operativa y bueno la razón por la cual
se usa un término distinto es porque
algunas veces podrías tener utilidad no
operativa entonces supongamos que aquí
de estos 10 millones en activo y al
principio no explique eso porque no
quería hacer las cosas muy complicadas
pero déjame con
ahorita entonces podría hacer que de
estos de estos 10 millones de pesos en
activo pues 9 millones si se han activo
operativo 9 millones a lo que me refiero
con la activa operativo es que son la
empresa son las cosas que se necesitan
para generar la utilidad operativa
fábricas y cosas así pero también
podríamos tener otro millón de pesos en
activo que no sean de esos o sea está
activo que la compañía no necesita para
operar y nada más lo tiene con él podría
estar especulando en precios de petróleo
o estar disminuyendo el riesgo de algo
con otras acciones o podría tener una
cuenta bancaria enorme entonces con este
activo podría estar generando un ingreso
no operativo entonces podríamos poner un
renglón aquí que dijera ingreso por
interés o ingreso por inversiones lo voy
a poner a su ingreso por inversiones y
entonces la compañía podría haber ganado
algo por eso de ahí digamos no sé de 10
mil pesos 10 mil pesos de ingreso por
inversiones esto cambiaría este renglón
a 510 mil pesos el impuesto cambiaría a
153 mil y entonces el ingreso neto sería
cuánto como 356 mil
pero así no 1 357 mil pesos verdad eso
tiene más sentido porque porque son diez
mil pesos más estamos para unos 30 por
ciento pues estamos pagando tres mil en
tres nada más ganamos siete mil más
verdad entonces nos quedaría siete mil
pesos más de modo que al final sería 357
mil pesos bueno entonces esta es la
diferencia entre utilidad operativa y
evite evite en este caso sería la
utilidad operativa más y este ingreso de
inversión entonces el ebit en este caso
sería un millón
con diez mil pesos un millón diez mil
pesos mientras que la utilidad operativa
nada más es un millón verdad bueno no
quería decir eso en el primer vídeo por
eso nada más dije utilidad operativa
dividida entre activos pero si realmente
consideras todo el activo verdad y
asumes que hay algunos activos que son
operativos que no están siendo usados
para hacer artesanías o para venderlas o
para no sé hacer marketing de ellas o
pagar al director general verdad si
consideras que hay esto entonces lo que
genera esto es pues un ingreso no
operativo entonces el ebit considera eso
de ahí el ebit pues lo podemos pensar al
revés que empieza con un ingreso neto
entonces luego le suma impuestos e
intereses mientras que utilidad
operativa es que empiezas hasta arriba y
bajas pero bueno en general si tomas el
ebit y quitas la utilidad no operativa
regresas a la utilidad operativa eso es
lo que es el evita bueno entonces pues
ya puedes imaginar que tanto ebit y la
forma en la que yo definí roa verdad que
es utilidad operativa entre activo pues
son formas de decir bueno antes de
considerar los impuestos
qué están haciendo tus activos por ti
déjame dibujar otra hoja de balance
activo pasivo podrías tener deuda verdad
pero podrías tener otro tipo de pasivo
los que podrías deber de verle a algunos
distribuidores pero aquí está el capital
bueno es importante siempre que hablas
acerca de cualquiera de estos
coeficientes en qué contexto estás
quieres pasar tu examen de la shoá o
impresionar a tu profesor o quieres
tener una mejor intuición para hacerte
un mejor inversionista bueno osea si
quieres ser un inversionista te conviene
más la tercera verdad para esto está
padre pensar que roa te está diciendo
pues qué tan buena es esta compañía
obteniendo un retorno de esta cosa de
acá del lado izquierdo no me importa
como pagaron por el activo si tienen
deuda no quiero saber de eso por el
momento no quiero saber si son buenos o
tienen una buena tasa de interés y el
director general pues no se sabe
platicar mejor con el banco o si sabe
evadir mejor impuestos que el de otra
compañía lo único que me importa es todo
el activo que tiene que también lo sabe
administrar qué tan bueno es haciendo
trabajar ese activo y obteniendo un
retorno
y utilizó este día causando ebit entre
activo o si utilizo utilidad operativa
dividida entre activo entonces y uso
cualquiera de estas dos definiciones de
roa y digamos una compañía a tiene un
rol de 10% y una compañía ve tiene un
rol de 15% entonces yo puedo decir sabes
que no me importa si ve es mejor
obteniendo una menor tasa de interés o
negociando tal vez no sea alguna ayuda
del gobierno de impuestos o haciendo
cosas así sofisticadas con donde tiene
sus subsidiarios lo único que quiero es
saber cuál administración es mejor
obteniendo retorno sobre los activos y
estas métricas justo me van a decir que
es a que dicen cuánto se hace cuanto a
utilidad operativa se hace con el activo
o te puede decir cuánto ebit en cuyo
caso el ebit puede ser un poco más
informativo porque considera ya sabéis
ingreso que es no operativo verdad
ok entonces tal vez la compañía tiene un
poco de acciones o un poco de oro y
también te interesa saber qué tan buenos
son generando un retorno a partir de eso
para ok entonces ese es el chiste en
general lo que quieres es pues encontrar
una medida digamos para el manejo de
activo ebit sobre activo es bueno y es
muy cercano a utilidad operativa sobre
activo bueno ya tenemos dos medidas muy
buenas pero entonces ahora me puedes
decir por qué existen estas otras
definiciones y por qué no te gustan
tanto bueno ingreso de tu interactivo
pues creo que la razón por la cual la
definición existe es porque uno pues el
ingreso neto tome en consideración pues
todas las cosas verdad y entre ellas hay
algunos factores que a mí no me importan
y eso pues no está mal o sea realmente
si podría tener sentido no sé o sea a
final de cuentas al final del día pues
vas a tener que pagar interés y vas a
tener que pagar impuestos al gobierno
federal entonces se está considerando
eso de ahí por eso esta definición pues
podría ser interesante lo que hacen es
tomar el renglón inferior y de ahí viene
la expresión renglón inferior viene del
estado de resultados el renglón superior
es el ingreso por ventas
inferiores ese reglón inferior del
estado de resultados de ahí vienen las
expresiones bueno entonces esa
definición toma esto y lo divide entre
el activo total pero la razón por la
cual no me gusta esa definición es
porque pues como que no se para muy bien
sea esta definición la de ingreso neto
entre activo no se para muy bien que una
compañía podría ser mejor pues evadiendo
impuestos o pagando impuestos o que tal
vez otra compañía sea mejor no sé pues
platicando mejor con el banco y esto yo
creo que no es lo que importa a mí lo
que me importa es el activo que también
maneja en su lado izquierdo de la hoja
de balance mientras que esta definición
toma en cuenta otras cositas del lado
derecho que no me gusta tanto no sé
déjame hacer un ejemplo supongamos que
tenemos dos compañías idénticas y creo
que este ejemplo va a ser muy
interesante para ver supongamos que
tenemos una compañía a ver voy a pintar
algo así gancho no es lo que quería no
sabes que de hecho se me está acabando
el tiempo mejor lo hacemos en el
siguiente vídeo con un poco más de calma
y voy a explicar un poco acerca de
ahorrar impuestos financiando té con
deuda va vamos a platicar por qué
convendría ok nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo